Opera has a reputation for being a bit
less accessible than other forms of
music but sometimes just a little
exposure can create a lifelong fan in
the case of a Texas native Latonya Moore
it went much further than that she
became an international opera star and
now she's incorporating her Jazz and
gospel influences into classical
performances trying to convince Skeptics
to give the art form she loves a second
chance from Washington Christina ruffini
has her story
[Music]
the desired effect that you want for
your audience is that they have
absolutely felt something
opera singer Latonya Moore likes drama
I want them to feel the gamut of emotion
you know like devastated if they're
supposed to feel devastated
[Music]
as Leonora in the Washington National
operas production of el trovitore
no she's had her heart broken drank
poison and become an unwitting player in
a very complicated and well sung Revenge
plot
I want them to feel like they really
went through it that's the point that's
for an artist up on the stage that's
what makes our heart beat for real
more becoming a classical opera singer
was and is a non-traditional process
because I was coming in here and you
could hear warming up Opera vocals
warming up and then we've got like like
this is what I play before I'm like
going out on a Friday night is this your
usual hype up routine yep it sure is
it's always just some kind of random pop
music hip-hop or r b rock
I like to just kind of loosen up and
just be me and relax my brain
growing up it was Jazz and gospel not
Opera that filled the family speakers
Moore performed some classical music in
school choirs but ultimately enrolled in
college as a jazz major and the teacher
says to me as soon as he hears me
warming up doing vocalizes
you're an opera singer I think that
Opera is for you you should join the
Opera chorus I joined the Opera chorus I
loved it what did you love about it
right at home I felt like
it was cool that I could act out any
kind of fantasy thing I'd ever been
thinking in my head like out on the
stage
the spectacle of a full-fledged
production like Verde at the Kennedy
Center means performers have to sing
through sword fights
navigate massive sets and endure a
marathon of unforgiving measures it's
very challenging it's very hard to sing
and it's one of those things that it
takes experience being able to negotiate
how you can handle the role stamina wise
does the fact that you had more of a
jazz background do you think that
influences and helps you in your Opera
roles I've LED it influence my style
sure sometimes to my detriment but it's
worth it
worth it to get to live out her
fantasies as a taffeta clad courtier or
an Ethiopian princess
uh feeling the energy it's unbeatable I
mean I need it it's my drug of choice
but Opera hasn't always chosen singers
who look like more
and although companies are getting
better at diversity making strides
towards colorblind casting Opera
especially in Europe is still struggling
with an outdated and controversial
practice darkening white singer's skin
to play non-white roles
coloring your body in order to portray a
role is just not necessary
anyone can look like anything it's our
job to show you that we are who we are
based on the way we sing Our roles the
way we sing the words it's gotten out of
hand what part of it's gotten out of
hand do you think that people insist on
doing it no matter what just because of
tradition but it was never necessary
don't have to do it please guys stop
for Opera to survive and flourish Moore
says it needs to focus on showing
audiences how relatable and modern these
centuries-old scores can actually be
there was a moment last night in the
Opera there are these two men like
screaming shouting singing over you and
your character just says Hear Me
[Applause]
and I think like we all just felt that
you could hear the audience kind of
laugh because it was like you're getting
mansplained to an Italian like is that
the kind of relatability stuff that
you're talking about oh my gosh
absolutely exactly that you know but I
mean how amazing that you're saying
something like that because the
relatability is absolutely there in
moments like that it doesn't matter if
you can't speak the language Moore says
the most important thing is to find an
opera that speaks to you
there's Opera for all and there's Opera
for all kinds of people you just have to
kind of open your mind and give it a
chance
for CBS Saturday morning Christina
rafini Washington
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's so true I love that moment that
Christina referenced also because that
is it it is find that moment that
relates and that's how you bring another
generation into it hear me yeah hear me
hear me stop mansplaining Jeff and the
the themes just are so relatable I love
the costume changes and bringing it up
to date to a new you know period in time
it's
it's classic what can we say that's
right